Salisbury Plain in southern England 2500
BC the same time as the pyramids in
Egypt are under construction workers
here complete the outer circle in
Stonehenge the hall huge rocks some
weighing up to 45 tons across rough
terrain they work each granite like
stone into shape then pull them up right
to form the great stone circle
thousands of people work on this massive
project
when they complete this phase an inner
horseshoe of five great arches will be
enclosed by a ring of thirty stone
uprights and topped by a circle of
perfectly horizontal stones called
entrance but while we know this was an
incredible feat of Engineering
who these people were and why they built
Stonehenge has remained one of the great
unsolved mysteries of the ancient world